empty rhetoric empty promises empty
shells and empty suit that's pretty much
sums up the joe biden presidency and now
he's so desperate for a political win
he's willing to go all out and try and
appease the radical extreme left who are
now pulling the strings and have been
pulling the strings of this failed
presidency for democrats joe biden it's
politics first it's you the american
people we're dead last here for reaction
leo 2.0 terrell along with fox and
friends weekend co-host pete heggseth
all right so
let's say i i i asked people to pick
race gender whatever two characteristics
only for people to fill in for the show
leo would that be right
uh i don't think so and i've been a host
of your show sean let me tell you right
now
we need to tell the audience and all
pete in all fairness you need to know
this
leo's filled in one time i've had to beg
leo to fill in that one time he i've
asked him ten other times hey leo what
do you want me out here peter leo hey
hey pete bailed me out leo has turned me
down
filling in on this show
me out here hey let's talk about the
subject what gives joy heart the right
to
to i i'm talking about the issue i'm not
talking what get but to answer your
question
this show this sean hannity show is
colorblind but what gives bayhard the
right to question clarence thomas
blackness this is nothing more than
pandering and it's insulting to black
americans because what they're telling
us is if you are black you have to be a
democrat tell that to hershel walker
tell that to condoleezza rice candace oh
and larry elder and leo terrell it is
insulting it is insulting because it
makes the mindset that we all think
alike black people have different views
and the comment to pick a black female
is racist it's the number one reason why
i left the democratic party because two
years ago joe biden said if you vote for
trump you ain't black the democrats the
left wing have divided this country sean
you say they played every election cycle
they're planted 24-7 and one final point
this is not going to convince black
people to vote for joe biden and the
democrats we hate crime we want crime
eliminated we hate these federal
mandates we want the homeless problem
done we want school choice that's what
black people want
you know pete let me go to you by the
way pete i need to thank you personally
because every time we've asked you to
fill in you've been very gracious uh
please
leo leo has turned us down at least 15
times actually my staff is saying in my
ear it's like over 24 times but i won't
bring that up
um so i thank you pete but in all
seriousness you know
we're we're supposed to be one american
family you know the coolest thing when
you take politics out of sports stephen
a and i go back and forth and text each
other about this occasionally you know
take politics out of sports what do you
have people with a shared passion a
sport shared passion a team a home team
high-fiving strangers all socioeconomic
backgrounds races religions
it doesn't matter
why don't we look for the right person
period
that's it if you're looking for two
things i'm looking for merit and i'm
looking for judicial philosophy and i'm
not going to agree with who the
democrats believe has the right judicial
philosophy that's that's life but that's
what it should be but we should expect
nothing other than this from joe biden
and kamala harris and let me tell you
why this is the least merit-based
presidency in american history as donald
trump pointed out barack obama pulled up
twice failed presidential candidate joe
biden because he felt like he needed a
white guy with experience and some
foreign policy experience even though
he's always wrong so barack obama wins
joe biden goes along for eight years
then joe biden when he stumbles into the
nomination because he promised a black
female to a black congressman in a state
he otherwise never would have won he
wins south carolina and moves forward
after really not being seen as a viable
candidate then he says i need to pick
somebody who should it be a black female
it's going to be kamala harris even
though she couldn't pull over one
percent so no one in is currently in
1600 pennsylvania avenue got there
because of merit so why would we expect
that this would be anything other than a
box checking identity politics
politically correct left-wing giveaway
based on rakes from the guy who sat in
front of clarence thomas when he said
this is a high tech lynching from the
guy who said they're going to put you
back in chains this is exactly who we
know barack obama or excuse me joe biden
is so it doesn't surprise me one bit and
i'll tell you this i'll i'm gonna text
leo after this he'll be hosting your
show next time you ask him i'll send him
straight at least somebody you know will
will help us out when we're in a moment
of crisis in need um the question i have
why does the media give biden a pass on
all the issues that pete mentioned on
race leo uh what i mentioned about
robert byrd i mean partnering with a
former klansmen no integration
uh racial jungles how does how did how
did the media just ignore all of that
very simple they are ages the media cnn
msnbc joy reid all those people who who
you play out they are ages of the
democratic party they are players of the
democratic party they were obsessed with
getting one of the greatest presidents
of all time out of office so they pick a
guy who is a racist you could play that
montage all the time back in the early
70s up until now joel biden is a racist
but they wanted him in lieu of president
trump and look what has happened to this
country in the last 12 months we have
lost our our direction because of joe
biden so to me the media is as as
responsible for the disaster of this
country as joe biden one final point the
only prime time show i ever go on other
than that one time with jesse water is
the sean hannity show
does that mean you'll fill in for me my
next day off
how about we do a poll
is going to win
pete i can't get him to do it maybe you
can talk him into it
you're tougher than i am you know what i
think we just leave him be it's the only
thing i've disagreed with 2.0 since he's
been 2.0 so i think we'll give him a
pass on this one
no pass leo's got a man up come on and
host the show leo next time i'm out
you're sitting in this chair or we're
just gonna we're just gonna have an
empty chair for the full hour uh co-host
with pete i co-host with pete all right
okay i like that too together actually
that would be pretty cool i'm not
disagreeing all right thank you hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else